hey whoa whoa whoa okay all right
immediately in the game hello hi there
how's it going okay click to escape
oh wait whoa whoa whoa click - click -
whoa what the wait a minute what's going
on I haven't even gotten in the game yet
hang on let me get my bearings I just
loaded this up and I'm very confused but
anyway welcome to let's play deep down
duck Ark another oculus rift horror game
it's supposedly a randomly generated
maze what is that is there lightning in
here alone is static poking me wait
static his slender poking me in the butt
with his staticky juices okay so yes
this is supposed to be randomly
generated whoa what the whoa what the so
I don't know I don't want to go down
there something seems very wrong over
there I'm gonna go over here starting
plan is on the gamepad but the
sensitivity for turning is very low
apparently and it's to click with the
mouse oh maybe I should be playing this
with the mouse and not the gamepad
Emelin but there's someone down there
don't better not be down there
hey all right so anyway what's on this
table here whoa whoa whoa huh uh yeah
press space and access some SuperDuper
awesome stuff so anyway Oh randomly
generated so I wanna oh yeah just like
just like that plop down things on the
ground to be able to go whoa
what what was that I didn't even see
what it was I didn't get a chance to
scare me I didn't see what it was
looks like some sort of spider nest
thing damn it
alright so left him in now I got another
choice
oh that goes down so let's go down here
maybe there'll be something scary okay
oh it is dark in here oooh hello hello
hello oh good and done I can feel a
Tesla's in my eyes okay so uh that was a
dead end
let me just go back without anything
happening okay all right
we're fine it's gonna just plop down
more rope plop down more yeah don't go
that way - dead end me okay alright so
the purpose of this game is just to
escape Oh
all right whatever let's go down whoa
all right then okay
Doughboy does that sound
someone's scratching on the walls over
there okay thanks for the illumination
still don't know what that is with the
light oh god another choice they look
the same but the noise is coming from
there let's go find out what it is
stupidly let's walk into the darkness
oh no it's more down oh it's way more
down holy crap I keep bumping my head
against the microphone hmm let's go I
guess oh okay alright alright
god damn more down oh I'm gonna find
something at whoa that is the most
ominous looking hallway I've seen yet oh
oh okay all right we're spiral stair
casing bye oh come on
ah I can feel that dirt ah okay then I
only caught like that glimpse of a
monster but I didn't even I couldn't
even tell what it was just took a dump
there I don't know what happened oh my
that was disorienting but okay god damn
we're down what is down here I don't
know
left or right dead end I guess the
choice is obvious okay down that way or
down that rather ominous looking one Oh
- ah something that time don't know what
it was it was like some sort of spider
it had four legs and a body I'm Subang
it was some sort of weird spider
creature all right okay so I don't know
if he's particularly threatening but he
exists that's a thing
okay whoa what was down that hallway
again I am waiting for the flash to come
back cuz I want to see what was down
that hallway I thought I saw something
oh really
but smaller slash possible Oh a dark no
no okay yeah the link is behind me I'm
not sure did you buy me what's going on
what is going on what are you going on
look of you
I'll talk if you I'll give you what what
what uh uh uh uh ah come on I thought I
was getting close to the end or
something who's down here staircase I'm
Tina staircase yet
why are you flickering bastard okay this
is pretty involved oh yes let's go this
way
I love it
I think it's behind me I think I think
is it I don't know
oh man I did make a big loop what's with
this what is with this it's it's it's
just it's a dead end
damn it what is with this table maybe in
like the final version there'll be some
symbol if I got to tie and then I'll
have to you know oh no I don't know lay
my X down here good great
I don't know what was going on back
there I dropped a lot of X's I just
sorry okay
what is that I see something here yeah
probably nothing go down oh I don't like
this game another creepy
uh okay well done I gotta say aw come on
I hear that scratching again oh oh boy
all right so anyway stop it okay all
right so I've cleared out this whole way
I thought I was actually going somewhere
but remember I was running away from a
monster I'm glad I managed to drop down
some X's so I know where I went oh I
thought it what was it again
is it even gonna is it even remotely
threatening I don't know if it Oh Oh No
thank you
ha it's on again okay it's not
particularly terrifying
I got it would
you
what is that it is pulsating it is
moving was it what is that Oh Oh what I
went away get me kidding me what was
that it was pulsating it ended so I was
disgusting that's what it was oh my god
I have no idea what that was it was
weird this there's more to this game
than I thought oh no no no no no no nope
ah
Oh thumbs up though it's weird because
it's that ah crap it's not like it's
very terrifying that thing whatever the
spider thing is but I mean with the
oculus rift it's kind of in my face when
I round the corner so that's why I
jumped I'm not a big baby don't don't
don't look at me like that I'm not a
scaredy cat it's just when something
goes in my face it's it's not it's a
reflex it's not so nevermind shut up you
guys wouldn't understand the pressures
of being a horror let's player okay ah
god damn it
okay gone both these ways before I
didn't lay down my ax
I didn't do that supposed to do that
always supposed to do that so if I have
to backtrack like this I know where to
go okay this way okay let's go down here
first what all right oh boy joyous day
frabjous day
Callooh Callay let's go down some more I
love that love that with all my heart
all my passion is speed passion is - try
to forget out a word how do i english
knew what i don't want to go back up but
this is the first time i've oh never
mind it was
rules for you are a master ruse man I
hear that scrit scratchin oh this is
brighter
this is brighter oh because it's two
dead ends whoa what what happened what
whoa what what what happened did I die
or did I win what what did I win did are
worn I I think that might have been the
end or a dead end of some sores I don't
know what I'm so confused
did I win I don't think what the aah
I've been burned alive in a journal okay
I think that I think I reached an end it
may not have been a good end but I got
to something so
okay